in the fifth episode of the original
series of star trek the show tries to
pass off what is clearly someone's dog
with a horn taped to its head as an
alien life form it's pretty hilarious to
revisit not just to see the actors make
a heroic attempt to stay in character
while carrying this thing around but
also because this unicorn dog doesn't
seem distinct enough from life on earth
to make a believable alien but this
raises an interesting question if there
is life elsewhere in the universe just
how alien will aliens look it's a
question many scientists and sci-fi
authors have speculated on and is a
fascinating rabbit hole to go down
so for this entry into the archive we'll
explore relevant phenomena in evolution
and physics to determine if
extraterrestrials are more likely to
look like earth animals or something far
stranger for our first example let's
start by imagining an earth-like planet
it's got a comfortable amount of liquid
water a protective atmosphere and plenty
of carbon to form the building blocks of
organic compounds if life emerges on
such a world what kinds of ecosystems
will form
one of the most important phenomena to
consider when imagining extraterrestrial
life is something called convergent
evolution
or the independent evolution of similar
features across different species
despite being part of different
evolutionary branches it's why echidnas
and hedgehogs look almost identical
despite one being a marsupial and the
other a placental mammal or why
hummingbirds and hummingbird hawk moths
are often mistaken for each other
despite their last common ancestor
predating the first land animal or why
crustaceans simply refuse to stop
evolving into crabs a trend we'll
discuss more in just a bit
with all these examples it feels like
nature is copying its own homework and
not changing things enough to get away
with it but evolution isn't a conscious
force though we often think of it that
way is the product of random genetic
mutations allowing certain members of a
species to better survive and pass on
their genes resulting in change over
time in a treat that benefits one
species might also benefit another in a
different time or place if they face
similar obstacles
one of the best examples of convergent
evolution is how sharks a type of fish
dolphins a type of marine mammal in
ichthyosaurs a type of extinct marine
reptile all evolved the same general
body shape despite coming from vastly
different lineages they all have
streamlined bodies tail flukes and
dorsal fins that are in roughly the same
place this is particularly remarkable
for dolphins and ichthyosaurs as neither
of them started off with any fins at all
as is often the case the main reason for
this seemingly miraculous convergence
has to do with physics simulations have
shown these body shapes are the optimal
way of moving through the dense medium
of water so natural selection encouraged
parallel attributes in each lineage with
the three animals essentially finding
similar solutions to the same problem so
on a habitable alien planet with liquid
oceans perhaps we'd find life forms with
the same general body plan swimming
beneath the waves
a more extreme example of convergent
evolution is how crustaceans just won't
stop evolving into crabs i told you we'd
get to it the number of times different
lineages have independently converged on
a crap like body plan is so high that
there's even a word for it carsonization
meaning to become crab-like
today there is a staggering array of
these crab mimics across the globe from
the tiny strawberry hermit crab that
feeds on seaweed to the coconut crab
that looks like it feeds on your
nightmares i've made jokes about
carsonization before on my channel
because there is something oddly
hilarious about the phenomenon are crabs
just the pinnacle of evolution what is
it about the crab body shape that makes
so many unrelated crustaceans seemingly
jealous enough to copy their style well
once again physics is our culprit the
long tails of crustaceans like shrimp or
lobsters can restrict the species
mobility by contrast the compact crab
shape is efficient and versatile with
few exposed parts that predators can get
to without getting pinched so there's
nothing mystical about why the crab body
plan is so trendy though it's fun to
think so it's simply a good answer to
the question of survival and likely
would be on other earth-like planets as
well
but these are all examples of
convergence in species that already have
a lot in common like eyes legs and a
skeletal structure if microbial life
were to emerge on an earth-like planet
would it really end up evolving these
structures in his book a zoologist's
guide to the galaxy cambridge zoologist
eric kirschenbaum reflects on how
certain features like eyes and limbs
might be more common across
extraterrestrial life than we'd think
the eye might seem like a unique feature
aliens wouldn't necessarily converge
upon but on our planet eyes are thought
to have evolved multiple times across
different lineages eyes likely emerge
from rudimentary photoreceptive organs
which some life forms on earth still
possess and then through natural
selection become more complex over
millions of years yet across these
variations eyes always serve the same
essential navigational function and on
another planet a creature's chance of
survival will also likely be higher if
they can see where they're going so if
the first aliens we encounter end up
having eyes it won't be that surprising
the same can be said for legs on earth
arthropods and vertebrates evolve legs
independently from one another after
emerging from the water while the shape
and number of legs might fluctuate the
mechanical advantages legs offer are
likely to be universal across earth-like
planets
even more fundamentally practically all
animal life on earth exhibits
cephalization or the concentration of
the mouth sense organs and nerve ganglia
on the front end of the organism
producing a head region
cephalization is likely the simple
result of the advantage that having the
part of the animal that goes forward be
the one fitted out with sense organs and
on most planets it'll likely always be
more important to know where you are
going than where you have been
even plants convergently evolve trees
that is to say large photosynthetic life
forms protected by a bark-like substance
have emerged many times from many
different plant lineages and the
evolution of fruits like apples happened
independently from fruits like tomatoes
with both of these shiny red fruits
emerging to get the attention of animals
that disperse their seeds after chowing
down likewise seed dispersal by ants has
evolved more than 100 times and is
present across more than 11 000 plant
species making it one of the most
dramatic examples of convergent
evolution in all biology
yet convergent evolution doesn't always
produce organisms that look the same
take for example the woodpecker a kind
of bird and the eye eye a kind of lemur
both of these animals occupy the same
basic role as predators who feed on
insects that hide within trees
woodpeckers get to these insects using
their beaks and eye eyes get to these
insects using their elongated somewhat
unsettling finger in terms of their
lifestyle these animals are quite
similar but you'd never mistake one for
the other this means that even if an
alien occupied a similar niche to an
earth animal there's not always a
guarantee they'd look alike so on our
earth-like alien planet we might find
mobile animal-like organisms with eyes
and limbs moving around stationary
plant-like life-forms occupying niches
that are familiar to us but they might
still appear pretty distinct from earth
life and certainly aren't likely to look
like the star trek dog still a majestic
creature though
but what about the possibility of aliens
with intelligence comparable to ours
would they evolve a convergent form on
an earth-like planet or would they look
entirely different the question of what
intelligence even means could probably
be its own video but for now let's keep
things simple returning to star trek
spunk is certainly a suspiciously
humanoid extraterrestrial with an
appearance identical to humans with the
exception of elf ears and funky eyebrows
this was more the result of budget
constraints than anything else but it's
a trend you see across a lot of science
fiction and while it's easy to assume
that an intelligent alien would look
like we do that's not necessarily the
case
human hands might seem like a tool
perfectly designed for crafting
technology but our hands didn't
originally evolve for manipulating
objects the digits we used to work our
smartphones began as a means to better
grip onto the trees we used to swing
through aliens would probably need
complex manipulatory appendages to
create technology sure but that could
take any number of divergent forms
likewise our bipedal stature might seem
ideal but ask any orthopedic doctor what
they think of our spines and you'll
realize the human body plan has some
definite drawbacks extraterrestrials
might want to sidestep of course some
things seem likely to be universal
across advanced life in the galaxy
they'd probably need a large brain right
well that might not even be the case as
crows have relatively tiny brains but
are able to solve logical puzzles and
use simple tools their dense brain
structure means they actually have a
similar number of total neurons to that
of primates and indicates that alien
intellects really might not need to
resemble the human form after all unless
they also happen to evolve from a
primate-like species that began walking
upright with all the planets in the
universe intelligent humanoid aliens
aren't impossible just not all that
likely
but it's time we address the fact that
not all planets are the same an
earth-like level of gravity for example
isn't a constant throughout the universe
our planet's gravitational pull is an
invisible yet crucial influence across
evolution on earth affecting the
parameters of animals body plans maximum
size and behavior so on a planet where
gravity is say significantly weaker
evolution might take a very different
path
one of the best depictions of low
gravity alien life comes from sam vilas
boas's speculative work of planet anew
which i've covered before on the channel
this evolutionary thought experiment
depicts extraterrestrials that take
advantage of their planet's weak
gravitational pull in a variety of ways
with many having tall spindly bodies
that wouldn't be able to carry their
weight on our planet
vilas boas does imagine some convergence
with earth life would take place on such
a world but there's also a variety of
life forms our planet could never
support
on the other side of the spectrum we
have the possibility of alien life
evolving on a world with a stronger
gravitational pull than our own
christian klein's speculative field
guide to alien life the teeming universe
which i've also covered before on this
channel gives us a look at a high
gravity world occupied by heavy slow
moving life forms on the fictional
exoplanet borehold klein imagines aliens
that creep slowly across the ground like
giant terrestrial starfish their bodies
built to withstand over three times the
gravitational forces we experience here
on earth
and dissimilar gravity isn't the only
variable that might make life on
exoplanets different from what we're
familiar with remember how i mentioned
alien life might have eyes well on a
planet with an opaque atmosphere where
energy comes not from a sun but say
geothermal vents you might see a world
of sightless creatures on earth many
deep sea creatures either have
undeveloped eyes or no eyes at all
so it makes sense that on an alien world
with very little light there wouldn't be
much point in having light receptive
organs and organisms might navigate
through their sense of smell or through
advanced echolocation
and even if a planet's surface is
inhospitable maybe some organisms could
thrive in a planet's atmosphere
returning to the teeming universe
there's a section of the book that
outlines the possibility of life
emerging in the stratosphere of a planet
somewhere between a terrestrial world in
a gas giant like jupiter the chapter
depicts extraterrestrials that float on
sacks of internal hydrogen steering
themselves through the air on
specialized fins the possibility of life
within the atmosphere of a gas giant has
been entertained by numerous scientists
over the years including carl sagan when
considering evolution on planets
different from our own extraterrestrial
life becomes less and less familiar
and things could get weirder different
planetary parameters aren't the only
factor when considering how alien
extraterrestrial life might be
so far we've been assuming alien
organisms would have similar fundamental
chemistry to our own but that might not
be the case crystalline life based on
the silicon atom instead of carbon like
life here on earth has been a topic of
discussion among scientists since before
the 20th century since silicon-based
bonds are most stable at high
temperatures such life might
theoretically thrive on planets with
high geothermal activity
even if we visited such planets we might
not recognize them as full of life at a
glance since such ecosystems might seem
barren to our eyes
now more recent studies have shown there
are some potential chemical pitfalls to
silicon-based life but it's difficult to
disprove such a theoretical concept with
any certainty who knows maybe somewhere
out there in the universe a
silicon-based scientist is working on an
article about how carbon-based life just
isn't possible in fact some earth
animals have been observed using silicon
in their structures diatoms are tiny
phytoplankton that encase themselves in
a wall made of silicate now these
organisms aren't silicon based but they
do show the material's potential to be
used in biological life and why stop at
silicon scientists at cornell university
have modeled a theoretical oxygen free
cell based on methane that could be the
basis for some really unusual life forms
protected by a cell membrane called an
isotosome able to withstand extreme
temperatures these hypothetical cells
could potentially survive on exoplanets
with weak atmospheres and going to the
most extreme scenario it's possible
there are life forms that our limited
view of the universe hasn't prepared us
for when it comes to extraterrestrials
we don't know what we don't know and
maybe our definition of life will prove
too limited in the infinite variations
of the cosmos
so where does all this leave us well the
truth is we can't definitively say what
aliens do or do not look like without
ever having met any we can make
inferences based on evolution on earth
but with a sample size of one it's
difficult to say how much we really know
about how life tends to emerge
with so many planets it's not a leap to
imagine that some alien ecosystems would
be somewhat similar to earth life while
others would be completely different so
if you're a world builder or writer
who's worried their fictional creatures
are too similar to earth life remember
that nature itself isn't always
completely original and if you're
worried your fictional life is too out
there remember that we are only just
beginning to discover what's possible
maybe one day we'll find an ecosystem
much like our own we're an ecosystem
that stretches the definition of life or
maybe we'll just find a planet full of
crabs
as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next video
you